[Music]  if you thought you were a Harry Potter  fan do you think you will ever outgrow  your love of Harry Potter no wait till  you see Shawn Mendes all that magic went  down during carpool karaoke on Mondays  Late Late Show with James Corden where  Shawn Mendes proved his love for Harry  Potter and fellow Canadian Justin Bieber  speaking of our friends to the north the  singer showed Corden his hockey skills  the only thing that drums Shawn's talent  on the ice his talent as an artist  [Applause]  Shawn's latest album dropped last month  here's what he told ET you just go  through this crazy rollercoaster as a  human and it's amazing and that's what I  wanted to write about I wanted to write  about the longing and the desire and the  love and the heartbreak and you know all  of those things and how it's not just  one of those things  you